real quick Donald Trump as you know if
you watched yesterday's show listen to
yesterday's show he announced that he is
going to be demanding an investigation
into voter fraud including people
registered to vote in two states this is
a voter fraud investigation that's
totally unnecessary it will use taxpayer
money for something that's been widely
debunked it turns out though you can't
write this stuff that President Trump's
own daughter Tiffany Trump is registered
to vote in both Pennsylvania and New
York heat street has learned as a
reminder remember this tweet from Donald
Trump where he said I will be asking for
a major investigation into voter fraud
including those registered to vote in
two states tiffanie Trump lived in
Philadelphia while attending UPenn
graduating in May and also registered in
New York now the reality is this is not
a big deal
as long as you don't vote in both places
that you're registered it's not a big
deal so this is not so much about the
hypocrisy of Trump but rather that it's
just not a big deal and even his
daughter did something which does not
break any law if you try to vote in both
places that's a different story though
I mean I'm much more interested in the
hypocrisy of Trump it reminds me of when
it came out that Melania Trump did those
modeling jobs in the United States yeah
when she wasn't authorized to work here
illegally of course that's okay if
you're a solve any of your purest
Slovenian model but not if you're a
Mexican blue collar worker yeah oh it's
totally different depending on your
background not only its if any Trump but
also remember the senior White House
adviser Steve Bannon is registered to
vote in Florida and in New York
according to the Sarasota Herald Tribune
it's almost like this is an extremely
common occurrence and not in any way
shape or form evidence of massive voter
fraud although to be safe maybe Trump
should be locking up his daughter and
Bannon until they get this whole thing
figured out but you know what this is
about this is about a crackdown this is
about doing an investigation that will
find something totally milquetoast about
dual registrations that aren't even
against the law I think I might be
registered in two places right now I
think I'm still registered in
Northampton Massachusetts if I were to
show up there I believe I'd be on the
voter rolls and I'm registered here in
Boston
so again Trump calling for in
investigation into something that's not
illegal but it will be used mark my
words if there is anything turned up by
this investigation even just a few
thousand people many of whom could be
college students like his own daughter
who were registered in two places even
if they've done nothing wrong it will be
used by the trumpets and the Republicans
to try to justify more voter ID more
more voter suppression it is absolutely
clear what they are trying to do with
this we've got a great bonus show for
you today including soaring sales for
George Orwell's book 1984 in the wake of
alternative facts and much more david
pakman.com slash membership coupon code
I voted 17 if you want we'll talk to you
on the bonus show